we've all seen bonfires at least once in  our life but how does a bonfire produce  heat you might just say that it's  because the wood is burning yes you're  absolutely correct the burning of wood  is a combustion reaction and the result  of it is the generation of heat a  combustion reaction occurs when a  substance or fuel reacts quickly with  oxygen  in this case it's a chemical reaction  happening between wood and oxygen now  think about this most of our furniture  is made of wood  and oxygen is present everywhere so why  doesn't our furniture burn please type  your answer in the comment section and  if you like this video please share it  [Music]